Blue's Clues is a kids cartoon of a  pride parade for you know preschoolers  because that's what we want for our kids  headed up by a drag queen and on one of  the Pride Parade floats was a child  beaver I don't think this is a mistake  um with a double mastectomy it's two  scars four kids a beaver a little Beaver  like so there might be pandas and bears  and whatever all the characters in this  cartoon with a mastectomy a beaver why  does a beaver need a mastectomy because  they're a trans kid in the they're  trying to be a trans Beaver right I  thought it was an interesting choice of  character to do that too to be honest  but yeah this trans movie of a nice sort  of showed him he's like what what and  then in about two minutes later he goes  checked on Snopes it's real I was like I  just shouldn't do yeah so they're  grooming these kids into this